where you from man I'm from Morgan Brown
I don't believe in ghosts I don't
believe in spirits Souls I don't believe
in afterlife I'm not Christian I'm
atheist so what's the Halal way to learn
how to do that stuff legal I just told
you one thing I just I believe in aliens
why would you put faith into aliens when
you've never seen them but you can't put
faith into God who's actually a Muslim
and we want good for Myron yeah my thing
is I always tell people look I I grew up
a Muslim I was born a Muslim my family
half of them are Muslim you could take
your shahada right now do you want to
and I've done a lot of her own no I'm
not perfect either obviously you know
that too if we die tomorrow are we gonna
burn an oven for
uh I would I would recommend everyone
have a look at Islam I bear witness that
there's a there's an Unworthy of worship
and Muhammad is the messenger Allahu
Akbar our brother in Islam Eddie from
the dean show is creating the dean
Center which is a Masjid and a dawa
Center which is going to help
non-muslims learn about Islam
Insha'Allah and the most beautiful thing
about this is that we can all be a part
of this we can all take part in earning
rewards from this simply by donating
whatever we can to make this a reality
we beautiful let's do that all right
let's click this link let's donate what
we can and let's make this a reality
Insha'Allah
[Music]
we have a lot to cover here and we're
going to as usual
we're going to encapsulate the truth and
deliver it to you in a way that many of
you can relate to with my next guest Ali
dawa
[Applause]
show
thank you
how are you doing brother Eddie
how you doing brother all the way from
London yes how you been good can't
complain
um
happy to see you
and happy to join you inshallah soon we
yes yes looking forward to it inshallah
soon okay all right we got a lot to talk
about uh before we get into
the main discussion there was something
else that came up
for those that don't know Neil deGrasse
Tyson is an American astrophysicist
author and science Communicator Tyson he
studied at Harvard University the
University of Texas so he's pretty much
a man of science and he was one of those
who was saying follow the science and
now he has this to say let me get you a
reaction point is apparently the xxxy
chromosomes are insufficient
because when we wake up in the morning
we exaggerate whatever feature we want
to portray the gender of our choice
either the one you're assigned the one
you choose to be whatever it is and so
now here so so now just to tie a bow on
this I say to you
somewhere I read
somewhere I think I read that the United
States was a land where we have the
pursuit of happiness
suppose no matter my chromosomes today I
feel 80 percent female 20 male I'm gonna
I'm gonna put on makeup I'm gonna do
that tomorrow I might feel 80 male I'll
remove the makeup and I'll wear a muscle
shirt
why do you care yeah what what why what
business it is it of yours
to require that I fulfill
your inability to think of gender on a
spectrum is uh is that other brother
with you what's his name zeeshan yeah
yeah he's here zisha where's he at
e
where's my brother zeeshan he's here the
man with the plan if he can't nobody can
how you doing brother
how are you okay yeah how you doing I
heard you in the background how you been
yeah
bro yeah just uh just trolling the dean
show you know uh trying to get famous
so have you guys both heard of this uh
Neil uh the grass Tyson I watched it
yesterday I'm absolutely that's why when
I was watching it um I was a bit
confused because I went to Deshawn I
said is he Pro or against because the
video it seems like he's against at the
beginning so I'm confused I'm like is he
against or is he probably I'm still
confident you know he's actually Pro
lgbqt which is pretty amazing because
he's supposed to be a scientist he's
supposed to be academically
intellectually honest a lot of people
when they're atheist they they say look
when it comes to science it's objective
and you know we can take it and you know
we rely on it over God and over
testimony so here you've got a scientist
now that's using the same framework and
uh he's arriving at the conclusion that
you can wake up and you can be a man the
next day you can wake up as a female so
uh it'll be interesting to see what
these atheists have to say frankly
it seems like now this is this is
anti-god obviously anti-science this uh
satanic rhetoric and there's a great
statement that the only necessary thing
for the Triumph of evil is for good men
to do nothing so we're trying to do
something to combat this and obviously
this is coming from people who you would
think you know would come out and speak
up but uh against this because they're
scientists but they're actually speaking
speaking uh towards this uh this whole
uh what do you want to call it I mean
this is this madness
you know you know the most um it's
hopefully it won't be a shock to most
people but the way things are at the
moment the LGBT are heavily uh
especially the LGBT Lobby is heavily
funding two aspects in particular and um
one is of course education that's why
they're on the board of a lot of these
uh
um universities especially in the US and
then they're funding the what is it the
medical industrial complex which which
some argue is actually more prominent
than the military industrial complex
because that's where most of it's going
to happen so there's a lot of big bucks
to be had
um from of course peddling this LGBT
thing and they've definitely got their
kind of eggs in the in the right basket
and they're leveraging people like this
frankly you can't necessarily be an
academic who wants tenure who wants
credibility who now will openly go
against LGBT T I mean that's what we're
seeing with with needle to Grass Tyson
we're gonna see he's going to be one of
many and uh no no one can kind of make
this claim I don't think so that science
is is objective and you know we can use
it to determine X and Y which I don't
think anybody in their right mind does
Ali would you agree when I say X and Y
you're talking about X and Y chromosome
come on G okay
what's the situation there in London
where you guys are are there's a big
Muslim Community there is there a good
pushback against a lot of this in the
schools because primarily you know this
is what's Happening Here is probably
happening over there they're pushing
this this sexualization of the children
in the schools so that they're they're
having this pretty much pornographic
content for four five six-year-olds
they're showing and and then when uh for
instance you have a someone who stands
up and shows this stuff and starts
reading from these books at a board
meeting even the board members are like
hey slow it down do we you know what are
you doing and then the person is like
hold on you can't even let hear me
reading this but you want to show this
to the children or they'll actually blur
it out on the news but they want to show
this to the kids
what's going on over there in your part
of the world with this I mean over here
yes I mean it's unexposed well you can't
say it's unexpected but the only kind of
religious group that's actually coming
to the to the front are Muslims and um
you'll see even the people that are
anti-islam like the the far right and
the the right wing even they are
appreciating the fact that we're coming
forward but the problem is that because
we're the ones with the loudest voice it
gets turned into a religious thing and
unfortunately
um not much gets done I mean we saw it
in Birmingham as well remember
um when you know Muslim parents said
they they had enough I we even saw in
Canada as well and there was a Canadian
Pastor that came forward we put on s2j
news.com that he came forward and he
said you know what thanks to the Muslim
Community but the thing is that I mean
Muslim Community comes with a sort of
kind of stereotype and a propaganda and
the media loves to kind of bash us so
for for I for it to be more effective
we're gonna need the Orthodox Jewish and
Orthodox or just the Christians in
general to come forward as well it's
going to have to be a team effort but I
I don't know if that that's going to be
happening but rest assured the Muslims
will will not take this lying down
frankly and that's what we're seeing
over here there is uh constant
challenges by parents there is a
pushback but unfortunately and sadly
we're seeing UK
I mean tag along with what's going on in
the US as well what do you think oh same
all right thank you for uh the input on
that guys let's uh keep moving along I
want to see um recently there was a
video that you made uh Ali dawa and I
don't know if you're familiar with um
the what did you call it the fresh and
the fitna what is it called uh
yeah uh so let's go ahead and I don't
know if you're also familiar with this
uh this young brother recently he
accepted Islam a lot of the youth follow
him uh sneaky sneaky uh what's his name
Nicos Nico yes the new generation coming
up
yeah and let's uh get into a couple uh
videos first here yep to kind of uh
see some of his views on a few things
and then I'm really impressed that he's
actually calling people uh to Islam yeah
yeah
and he just and you just you just want
to protect them just naturally you
you're you feel more like a man because
you want to protect and you want to
provide for or you just want to create
that nice environment for this beautiful
feminine woman and then you realize
they're like the amount of that
you need to put up with with these women
in America how combative they are and
everything in the culture is steering
them away from being feminine it's like
it's like now you this it's just the
cardi B thing you need to be the Tip-Top
guy in order to make a woman submit but
women are happy to just do that in Japan
what do you think well yeah it's it's
it's true this is this is what it is
Islam has given a solution to all
problems in all Matters from marital
disputes to business to rebar interest
to uh sex outside of marriage Islam is a
holistic way of dealing with these
matters and Islam deals with it at the
core and it and its main principle is
that prevention is better than cure so
the thing is it goes back to you know
the worship of Allah so you see this
with different people in different
aspects when they see that there is no
solution what they do is they obviously
start seeking either they start try to
start a movement which the red pill did
so with snico and Myron and the rest
they started this movement because they
saw that the degeneracy and whatever's
going on
um you know and to be honest you know
the things that are going on and they
try to make their own movement and when
people like when somebody's sincere when
they come across Islam or a specific way
of life you you know which Islam is the
only one to be honest and they see that
they're like you know what this has
already been here from day one we just
need to follow this we don't need to
make our own movement because our own
movement is going to come with this
flaws that's why I've done a video about
fresh and fit you know because at the
end of the day yes I understand they are
trying to
they are trying to deal with an issue
but they are they are human beings and
anything that's man-made is never going
to be perfect so that's why they would
come with stuff like oh sleep around and
do this and do that there is truths to
uh some stuff that they say uh but
that's why if you look at people like
sneako when you're sincere like Andrew T
is well when they came across Islam they
said this this is this gives a perfect
solution so they came to Islam
alhamdulillah is a solution to uh many
of the problems and that's why you see
these prominent individuals who are
coming to it's not the flocking system
and it's I think it's a miracle you know
in the sense like Islam is one of the
most you know hated religions uh
misconstrued misunderstood on purpose
and
um Islam has been attacked the past
decade or so by individuals and the main
arguments they have is Islam is
intolerance Islam is intolerant Islam is
in tolerant Islam Islam that but now you
see people are coming to Islam because
of his intolerance like to me it amazes
me it amazes me that they are coming to
Islam because of his intolerance
of Allah yeah so he's on point here I
mean this goes with Islam that uh calls
the man to be masculine
and obviously mascara doesn't mean that
he's like you know impressor or whatnot
he's a maintainer protector of his
family and then he calls for the woman
to respect her husband and to to be
feminine right where it's not this like
he's talking about it's always this like
two Rams now trying to figure out who's
in charge
this correlates out with with Islam
feminine versus masculine let's go into
this next one here see where you from
man uh I'm from Oregon I don't believe
in
your life I'm not Christian I'm atheist
I believe in aliens why would you put
faith into aliens when you've never seen
them but you can't put faith into God I
won't believe in a higher power but I'm
not going to believe okay Christianity
seems to be the problem but you believe
that there's one higher power
you're a Muslim that's what Muslims
believe because I don't think like one
person it's not one person we don't draw
God the way Christians do Muhammad
brought the final message of God I mean
you could take your shahada right now do
you want to yeah I've done a lot around
once you become a Muslim you're forgiven
I bear witness that there's
an Unworthy of worship and Muhammad is
the best
[Music]
he went from mocking to getting exposed
to Islam and having some debates and
then he ends up accepting Islam and now
he's uh doing dawah he's actually got
he's calling people to take their
shahada what do you think did snico ever
mock Islam
at one point yes yes I did it I didn't
even know that okay interesting but
again it just showed you know there was
people who were um you know more
misguided than that who came to Islam so
yeah it's amazing I didn't actually see
that video that's quite impressive uh
yeah like alhamdulillah you know it's
nice to see um you know when somebody
really internalizes you know with me as
well like when I first came to Islam
it's the same thing when you realize
what Islam is and what it gives you once
you truly truly you know understand it
you know and when Iman enters your heart
Faith enters your heart then it's
something that you you want to share
with the world you know and that's why I
don't blame him I I totally relate with
him where when you are practicing this
faith and you've been lost you've been
blinded spiritually you know your
heart's been blinded and then you find
the truth you want to share with the
world and that's why I've seen snico
like right now uh you know I knew he was
doing Tower but I didn't know he was um
against as well so I'm very happy very
pleased
um and yeah may Allah keep him firm and
increasing my knowledge
um and yeah look at the end of the day
not myself I'm Mohammed hijab and many
other people who are out there can help
him with his intellectual arguments to
sharpen it to be you know more in line
with the Quran so I think it's great
it's a great asset and I think he should
definitely get in contact with Mohammed
hijabes many other brothers like that
inshallah and sharpen up his skills
because he's definitely got the
potential uh the style uh you know the
eloquence you know the guy Marshall has
got great potential and it'll be amazing
to see him you know he can be you know
sneakodawa
sneakodawa huh yeah he's also he's went
out of his way he connected with uh and
also yeah yeah yeah so how'd a lot it'd
be good uh there was a there was another
this guy I thought about you guys there
because I interviewed young just another
young young brother he's probably around
21 I believe and he was uh connected
with someone that you know that you had
um uh many encounters with what was his
name uh no he wasn't connected with him
but he ended up come get this so there's
this comedian actor named Owen Benjamin
I don't know if you've heard of him Owen
Benjamin he was with uh the likes of
like Joe Rogan on his podcast and
Hollywood and whatnot anyways he went
from being a screenwriter for the louder
for Crowder show okay okay and he went
and this is where you come in he was he
wrote the the theme song or a song for
what's that guy that you were
confronting many times
Tommy yes Tommy Robinson so look big
islamophone mocking Prophet Muhammad he
went to
um uh louder for Crowder Tommy Robinson
writing songs for him also some theme
Anthem that he used to sing to to
actually
changing his ways started talking
positively of prophet Muhammad he
actually says peace be upon Him wow uh
denouncing much of the Trinity so close
to accepting his mom but the way he was
talking got this guy that I just
interviewed this this brother uh his
name is Ibrahim now and he ends up
accepting Islam because of this guy
wow is amazing huh how things just
turned around that's amazing who's this
person
he's from Scotland he's from Scotland
yeah so he's uh yeah I'll have the
program out I'm sorry maybe you've seen
some of his stuff but so this is just to
go online this is how things can go
ahead and change it's amazing exactly
you know it's like I said before you
know we've dealt with the we've been
dealing with the atheists the Christians
the Hostile ones by the way the atheist
Christians you know we're the zionists
you know the the ex-muslims you know uh
who have now all disappeared you know
the the you know there's no more money
to be made so you can see all of these
people and the main thing they were
capitalizing on was you know Islam's
treatment of this Islamic treatment of
that the capital punishment and now it's
so it's it's crazy it's the biggest slap
in the face that one of the most
search man on Earth and many people like
him who are flocking to Islam and they
are flocking to Islam because of Islam's
stance so the Christians think that the
more you're tolerant and the more you're
like yeah we accept everybody and yeah
whatever it may be and you're going
against your own scripture by the way
your scripture doesn't say that your
scripture does not say we accept
everybody Jesus clearly says on the last
days he will come and he'll be
slaughtering people you know that those
didn't believe in him so you're going
out there and portraying
um literally turning it back against
your religion and it still didn't work
whereas Islam and the Muslims we stuck
by and said yes Islam yeah there's those
punishments in the year 100 and we
accept it and it's a haq and what's
happened now is that we didn't back down
those who back down left their religion
uh because they had an inferiority
complex now you are seeing people
flocking to Islam why because of Islam's
intolerance because of Islam's
principles because of Islam's way is
that not a big snap in their face just
imagine for 10 years the effort they
were put in and they were thinking they
were making some points and this and the
prophet's marriage to Aisha and the
capital punishment for the ex-muslims
and this and that and now you've got
people flocking it didn't work it didn't
cause people to not come to Islam it's
caused more people to come to Islam I
genuinely see this as a miracle I see it
like it's it's so profound imagine that
giving your effort and time to make
Islam vilify it and the very thing the
arguments you're using are the reason
why people are coming to Islam you can't
make this stuff up
amazing subhanallah let's get into this
next video that's interesting this was
uh brought to my attention and it goes
with in line what many things we're
going to be talking about and this is
the original sneako that we just were
talking about he actually he did a
reaction to a video you did
with a Muslim
who is part of this uh fresh and fresh
and fit or yeah Myron yeah yes Myron
who's actually a Muslim and we want good
for Myron yeah and let's go ahead and
get into this and we'll get your
reaction we'll discuss this
when did you take him I kept saying
Haram for like a lot of women sleeping
around but apparently he's saying like
there's 100 lashes for men too yeah
I've known that since I was a kid but
remember when we were having that
discussion I wasn't framing that
conversation in the context of this let
me get let's give a little bit of a
background so you actually did can you
break down you did a video and give an
introduction to what they're actually
talking about so in the video there is
basically they're just talking about
how basically there's this perception
that it is Haram for a woman to sleep
around
um but the way they make it out to be is
and I think yeah like I don't think
Myron really came from it from religious
angle I think it was more sneaker
another brother uh but I've seen this
around but again as a Muslim I know
Myron doesn't claim to be a perfect
Muslim and he wants to practice and I
saw this video you sent to me yesterday
I didn't know and he was admitting that
he wants to become better Etc and I
admire that look I'm really happy in two
occasions in the video he mentioned that
uh maybe I've done the video for clicks
um and yeah I would say look it can come
across like that at the end of the day
maybe the world that he's in a lot of
people do things for clicks and Etc I'll
be honest with you I you know you can't
open my heart but I didn't do it for the
clicks or the views I've done it because
genuinely I was like why they keep
repeating this because at the end of the
day our religion tells us in the Quran
that you should be just even if it's
against yourself or your kin even if
it's my dad or my mom whoever it is I
have to be just so in these elements if
that was a Muslim sister talking about
this everybody will go mad but why is it
okay for a Muslim man I don't give his
practice not practicing to make it seem
as if it is okay for a man to sleep
around and that's the reason I've done
that video to say look this is not
correct because a the punishment for
dinner is the same for a man and a woman
the punishment if you're if you are not
married is the same if you're married
the capital punishment is the same if
you die the the punishment in the
Hereafter is the same so I've done that
video just to
kindly tell them you know that they
shouldn't be repeating this Etc
um and yeah that was it really like that
was the main point of the Crux of the
matter okay so that's that's what it
revolves around let's continue on time I
was framing that conversation in the
context of human evolution and human
biology and what men actually want
it was if you notice I never mentioned
anything about the Quran it's Salim and
you that are mentioning the Islamic
stuff but like and here's the thing I
know I'm not the best Muslim so I rarely
ever bring Islam into the situation like
I never try to rationalize how I do
things with with Islam and my thing is I
always tell people look I I grew up a
Muslim I was born a Muslim my family is
very religious but I pretty much ended
there and I never try to talk about the
book or talk about the religion to
justify the way I behave right now with
that said
this conversation I was talking strictly
human evolution biology most men have
given the choice will prefer more women
I didn't meet I did I never mentioned
anything with Islam and that's you know
I guess maybe he's thinking like because
Saleem was mentioning it and like you
had mentioned it a little bit that like
we're all kind of in collusion to talk
about Islam in this situation in my
situation no I was just strictly
referring to human evolution that's fair
yeah you never bring it up and I never
bring it up in my debates like girls
will ask me why do you want four girls
I'm like well the wow was raised you
know you can have up to four wives Etc
and hahaha it's kind of a joke but um
you know eventually I'm gonna find a
dean and come back and everything else
like that and have you know my plan is
to have is to become a better Muslim and
have four wives but right now I'd be
lying to myself if I said oh yeah I'm a
great Muslim right now like no no I
don't want to be happy you've never made
that claim yeah like so
but yeah I think that's what it is he's
critiquing this but it's like I'm not
even making the Islamic arguments that's
true that you kind of blame me and
Celine for that in this video yeah yeah
okay let me kick it off so here's what
here's what I could really respect about
the brother and and um
and we both want good for this brother
and we coming from a background myself
also who is somebody who went through a
similar lifestyle you did also I liked
the point where he's he's he doesn't
justify his behavior islamically you
know it reminds me of myself anytime
back in the day when anybody would start
talking about God you know people throw
different topics around I would shut my
mouth I would just out of respect I
would be quiet and it seems like he he's
he's even though he's doing certain
things that he shouldn't be doing
inshallah he changes his ways uh he he
he's saying that now I never tried to
use Islam to justify the way I behave
he's acknowledging that what do you
think
yeah look at the end of the day like I I
admire the fact that you know he's
saying that he wants to become
practicing one day Etc and look it's
never too late for that and I think he
should really really um
capitalize on that because at the end of
the day he's lived a specific lifestyle
and you need to understand that I'll get
the eye for him I think it'll be very
powerful I'll try to find it because
it's a very powerful verse in the Quran
Allah clearly says that Allah sends
signs and
um he sends these signs over and over
again until the person is adamant in his
way he's adamant in his way then Allah
says in the Quran open the verse so I'm
specifically inshallah that Allah says
then we open the doors to everything
meaning we give this person a sign and
sign and sign again to turn back to us
to repent turn back to us repent if he
persists we will open the doors for him
meaning the stuff that is so pursuing so
much be woman money cause whatever may
be earning this in a Haram way because
there's Halal way to go about this stuff
and then Allah says we open the doors
for him and when he thinks you know he's
when he's boasting as if he's you know
reached those Heights or whatever maybe
we snatch his life we take his life
suddenly Allah says suddenly we take him
so to me it's like look I come from a
jahilia brother Eddie used to you know
Club in party and all this kind of stuff
girls you know there's a certain time
where I I always questioning myself I'm
34 years old uh Myron is one year
younger than me and I used to ask myself
like imagine myself living that
lifestyle to this this age I mean I
don't know what I would have done I
don't know if I would maybe lose my mind
be on drugs uh suicidal I mean what
would I be doing I couldn't imagine
myself repeating the same cycle over and
over again I would say to my dear
brother Myron you know genuinely when I
did that video I was not doing it for
clicks I wasn't doing it for this or
that I genuinely done it because at the
end of the day
these non-muslim women should not think
and be under the assumption that Islam
says one rule for a woman another rule
for a man no no no no because it's a big
big misconstruation uh you know it's a
lie and I'm not saying Myron said that
but the point is what happened on the
show so I would say my dear brother you
know you're a brother in Islam we have
love for you like we don't I genuinely
didn't do that to capitalize on your
name or this Stuff Etc genuinely I
didn't I done it because I don't want my
religion to be seen a certain way you
know so that's why I done that video
because I know a lot of people watch
your video and those people that watch
your video I mentioned you guys so they
can watch a Muslim reacting to that so
it's never too late repent because there
are certain things that you mentioned
which I don't want to repeat and you
know the lifestyle that you live in my
brother when is the time going to come
you can die any second who has given you
who's promised you so I'm just saying to
you this as your brother that I've lived
that kind of Lifestyle to an extent
maybe not as you know wild as you guys
do but
stop and say you know what Allah has
given me an option you know you can have
four wives like you said bro go get four
wives all day every day you've got the
money you can manage you can you know be
just to them Etc go and get married go
about the Halal way it is are we it is
impossible for us to say that a man
desires something but Allah hasn't given
a solution Allah has probably four wives
are more than enough for you I promise
you two wives is more than enough more
than enough in today's time I wouldn't
recommend any brother to get more than
two wives three boys
even if you're if like even if it was a
multi-millionaire how are you gonna it's
hard
the kids two wives perfect alhamdulillah
so brother go get your my uh your wife
firstly repent number one accept and say
you know what I've lived that lifestyle
Allah has allowed me enabled is giving
his Mercy out of his Mercy that I
haven't died with these sins these are
going to be all in your account Aki it's
not hard to repent please go and repent
number one and the conditional
repentance is what number one you hate
the sin yes dislike the sin don't be
proud of the sin number two try to stop
the sin and number three try not to go
back to the sin this is and if you make
a sincere repentance Allah is the most
merciful the most forgiven inshallah
you've got nothing to lose to repent
please brother Myron whoever is watching
this repentant as we speak in Shalom
good you don't need to announce it if
you're watching this you're hearing this
go home repent and say my Lord forgive
Me Guide Me accept my repentance be
sorrowful hate hate this sin
alhamdulillah inshallah accepts it
because if you die on that my brother
yes we know that eventually the Muslims
I think you mentioned this as well but
eventually the Muslims are going to
enter Paris he said we don't believe
that we don't believe the people of the
book will eventually enter Paradise they
would if they die on this belief and
know Islam is the truth this eternal
Hellfire for them if they know Islam is
the truth so as a Muslim man if you die
you don't want to visit Hellfire
Hellfire is not a it's not
somewhere where you're like I'm just
gonna go stop there for a couple of
weeks have a little holiday I don't even
want to go near Hellfire I do not want
nothing to do with Hellfire zero I don't
want to know it I don't want to see it
and of course as Believers we're going
to Allah is going to show us it but
obviously we won't be scared in
the Quran the Believers will not grieve
nor shall they fear so we want nothing
to do with Hellfire I want nothing to do
with the punishment of the Grave I don't
want nothing to do with
Myron
there's a few things you mentioned Etc
repent my brother Allah is the most
merciful and Allah says in the Quran oh
my servants have changed against
themselves do not ever despair the mercy
of your lord indeed Allah is the most
merciful so I would invite my brother
Myron inshallah please for the sake of
Allah just repent in private bro and
just slowly work on yourself and believe
me and one last thing I don't want to
give a lecture one last thing my brother
I know I've lived the lifestyle yeah
there's certain habits that I had that I
thought I don't know how I'm gonna let
go of this I don't want to go into
detail I really hated it I hated the sin
and I was like how do I let go of this
and any time you have a doubt about
yourself which I did and many people not
a single person on this Earth can leave
a sin by himself not to a certain single
person in this life can practice by his
own will not just that any time you
doubt and say that thing is too hard I
can't do it just remember you're right
you can't do it but Allah can make you
do it when you have Allah on your side
he can make you do it the most
impossible thing that you'll be like oh
I could never do this
Allah will make you do it you'll be even
shocked and that's how I've left certain
sins because Ali couldn't do it but when
Ali turned to his Lord and said my lord
I can't do it you help me indeed Allah
came to the rescue Allah came and helped
me and gave me the power and the
strength for whatever it may be from the
scene or the Unseen that I left that
lifestyle and there is nothing special
about me there is nothing special about
Miyaki I just asked and I got it
so we're here with Ali dawa we're doing
a reaction to a reaction so they were
reacting to your videos
double reaction it's the double reaction
I like what you said uh and this is real
important and this is out of the love
that we're reaching out to these
brothers and inshallah this could be a
benefit and I see in both of them you
know because you look back and you see
where you where you were where they are
now and you want people to to come out
and I'm seeing sneak also part of my
past you know when I start practicing uh
you want all your boys
to become your brothers and the dean
right so now he's sitting there and he's
actually indirectly subtly he's given
dawah to uh yes to the brother what's
his name in my room Myron so he he's
actually doing this he's calling sitting
him down and now the message Allah is
sending signs through sneako to Myron
how how I mean what else can it be it's
a mate if he really exactly if he really
reflects this is another sign another
thing Ali is that many people they
really get deceived you heard him say
that he wants to come back eventually
I'll find the dean and come back who
guarantees you that who guarantees
you're going to live till tomorrow you
know and I make an example I tell people
often I say look it's like every day
you're acquiring more and more felonies
imagine now and I think um he used to be
a cop or something so imagine someone
who's just every day acquiring more and
more felonies and at any times the
police now can come and lock you up for
life imagine so these crimes now that
we're we're doing against the crater
against the law against ourselves now at
any day the angel of death can come
snatch your soul and now you didn't
accept the signs
that are coming to you and you think
like you know I can go back and redo the
test once the test is over it's finished
once the police lock you up that's done
you can't go and say oh give me another
chance I'm not going to carry you know
the Coke in the back or break the laws
I'm going to be you know a good citizen
no but Allah has given you time right
now to go ahead and just turn back and
get things right and what does it this
is and what's it require just repentance
that's it Toba
simple and now what's the thing and have
a simple uh his his thing I can see is
that addiction to women now
and this is
it's in the Quran the things that men
desire you don't want to covet the most
number one is women
it's a matter and the cat takes five
minutes
between Halal and Haram
I find it amazing
I can remember when I was getting to
know my wife for marriage and we had
marriage meetings you know where we
would meet you know with someone from
her family and obviously they would let
us walk you know if we're eating
whatever and I find it so profound that
I would say to I would say you know
what's stopping me from touching your
hand it's Allah like just think of it
there is nothing that can stop me from
touching you except that Allah has made
it haram it's an invisible like some
people come and say like really I'm like
yes really until we do that Nikka I'm
not touching you and it is so amazing
that this is what we believe this is our
religion this is tawheed that we know
Allah deserves our
obedience and we believe that Allah is
the most merciful and that is the only
thing that is stopping and wallahi all
it does it requires is for you to go
have a the Father the permission of the
Wally have two witnesses alhamdulillah
and establish in a matter of 10 minutes
you are married between Zina and Halal
like the the companions came to the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
said you know the prophet said to them
that you get rewarded for having
intimacy with your uh um with your wife
and they said how really they said do
you not get a sin when you commit dinner
they said yes then how can it be that
you don't get a reward when it's halal
so the option is there not only is it
Halal but you are in a form of Charity
when you are having intimacy with your
wife and when your wife is having
intimacy with you this is our religion
this is what Islam has come to do so my
brother instead of indulging in these
sins with these women Prophet take the
Halal option take the Halal option is
please your Lord please yourself in the
Halal way and inshallah also being good
to your wife taking care of her because
you don't want to carry those bad traits
off you know you need to understand
these things have an impact on our heart
that's what Allah says
don't even come near it you need to also
I would say personally myself to Myron
yes it's true we want you to get married
however my personal advice which is
taking it to the next level bro is detox
because you're coming from that
lifestyle I would say bro take a good
couple of months out away from all women
connecting to your lord repenting
cleansing yourself because you don't
want to carry these things that you
already have to a marriage that you
might break so I want to give you
sincerence here that take that gradual
step you know get closer to Allah his
kitab and slowly slowly improve yourself
repent from it it's not going to be easy
Allah says in the Quran don't say I'm
I'm going to build I say I be a believer
and not be tested you are going to be
tested so I would say and start a family
start a legacy that you always talk
about inshallah and that you
Islam in a way where not the old style
lifestyle but it's someone that lived it
that is going to inshallah change other
young men to not go down this route
he's probably uh before we go on to the
next things he's probably because Islam
is practical I mean you know step by
step and he's probably got uh how many
girlfriends he cut back on a few and the
four that he has right now
turn it into uh yeah yeah definitely you
know or you know just you know if these
women are not good for you leave them
and find you know inshallah yeah
inshallah try to find a wife I would say
you know then I said that I gave yeah
and gradually and slowly yeah do those
changes yeah
all right let's continue on here yeah no
I'm not perfect either obviously you
know that too if we die tomorrow are we
gonna burn an oven for committing Zetta
uh
uh no I mean at some point you you know
all uh I'm not mistaken if I remember it
correctly all people end up going to
heaven that are people of the book you
know at some point you do yeah you'll
have to suffer in hell for a bit but but
yeah but yeah if I were to die right now
yeah I'll probably die Cafe
which is not good
so I better stay alive and get my
together at some point yeah don't die
that's why you stay ready yeah
it seems like uh sneakos I mean he's uh
a little playful but he's worried he's
more worried and you can see both of
them when he said are we gonna in an
oven and this is the truth man you don't
want to be burning for a second in the
worldly fire like Hamed Ali used to take
the match he said man Muhammad look he
would say Ali Muhammad Ali the great
Legend right he would say look you know
if I can't take this fire how am I going
to take the real fire you know 70 how
many times hotter uh so they're sitting
there for a minute thinking about it
then he's like nah don't fool yourself
Brothers yeah and the thing is it's like
they were like okay yeah we need to make
sure we don't die the thing is the death
is not in your hands tomorrow today
exactly anytime so the thing is like
you know it's like you're acknowledging
that you know uh we shouldn't die
because that would happen but who said
death is in your hands the fact that you
acknowledge the death is not in your
hands should be a U-turn for you and
again
if somebody's repenting like uh think
what's come to Islam uh in shahada it
raises all his sins uh except those he's
maybe wronged people or borrowed money
or whatever the the right of the people
are separate but in this situation
sneako obviously if he's repented if
he's come to Islamic he's got clean
slate
um unless he's you know been coming
since as a Muslim again you can repent
uh with my own you know he says
something like you know um dying you
know die as a cafe no no you're a
Believer so you won't die as a
disbeliever
um but the thing is again it's just like
look you've got nothing to lose repent
uh build that connection with your lord
believe me there is nothing no woman I
promise you there is not a single woman
on this Earth that will give you the
pleasure that you will have
with your connection to your lord and
understanding why you're here where
you're going that is true contentment
bro there is nothing on this Earth that
is going to ever replace that I promise
you no woman no money no car no nothing
once you have that connection with your
lord and you understand why you're here
where you're going who your lord is what
he wants from you that is the best thing
that you can ever have and there is
nothing I will I'll replace Islam with
nothing because it gives me true purpose
true contentment I know why I'm here I'm
not confused who put me here where am I
going why is this happening why am I
being ill why am I being tested
everything makes sense to me everything
is made sense to me so I would say to
Myron that um yeah like please just Aki
you know where your brothers you can
reach out to us you don't have to you
can reach out to your other Muslim
friends
whoever inshallah just reach out and
please just change your 33 years old now
um now is the time man definitely could
be around the corner
and again this is out of the love Yeah
Yeah 100 absolutely yes so let's go
ahead and continue your best your best
friend you have in this life is the one
who is the one who calls you to God I'm
telling you there is no other friend any
friend that turns you away from the
remembrance of God is a fake friend he's
an enemy anyone that you deem to be an
enemy who calls you to the remembrance
of Allah is your best friend
reminds me of that I'm in the Quran
paraphrasing where Allah is describing
the scenario for the person who is like
I wish he's wishing now that he had
found a way with Allah with the Creator
and the messenger and he sees people in
the Hellfire and he says oh you know
he's so thankful for the person in
Paradise like man I'm glad I didn't
follow such and such and he's seen
people in the Hellfire right he says
he's describing the scene yeah in the
Quran uh the Allah opens the a window
for him and he looks at the health and
he sees his friend and he says if only I
didn't stop hanging around with you I
was gonna be there with you
only are they make a swift decision of
say you know I have to cut this guy I
was gonna be there with you
that's some
I mean this is powerful this is
authentic Hadith describing the
description of people burning in an oven
can you imagine it's just horrifying you
know why and these things are there to
shake you up
to straighten you up exactly that's what
Allah says in the Quran we send a small
Calamity to divert a big economity the
small calamities of things on the
day-to-day life that we get hit disease
loss of money loss of family members
loss of this loss of that these are the
small calamities Allah sends to divert
you to a from a big Calamity which is
what Hellfire brother any test in this
life you can put up with but Hellfire
you cannot put up with that so if that
little Calamity is going to fix you up
and make you realize that is the best
thing that has ever happened to you
because when you stand in front of Allah
and you realize a Calamity that he will
be be it a disease be a loss of money
whatever it may be if you realize that
was the very thing that made you start
practicing and repent and close to Allah
you're going to be thanking Allah oh
Allah thank you so much for sending me
that Calamity that fixed me up that I'm
standing in front of you today with
goodies and I'm going to enter Paradise
that is where Allah says we send a small
Calamity to divert a bigger Calamity
which is the Hellfire
subhanallah let's continue on I don't I
think it's true they said like I don't
want to the girls will say like I don't
want a guy who's ran through have you
ever stumbled upon Roblox like has that
ever mattered to a girl uh no it never
does and I would argue if you exemplify
traits that show that you are
promiscuous you will be more attractive
versus if a woman shows Trace that shows
that she's more promiscuous it will be
less attractive I think girls say that
because they think men and women are
equal and they say that to try to like
virtue signal or whatever but the
reality is girls want guys that can at
least be able to have sex with other
girls I'm not saying you have to enact
on it but they want a guy that can do it
and also they want you to be able to
know what to do without even I mean with
the the I hate to keep using the value
statement example but like I asked the
girls what do the average body count is
the average ended up being like 20 30
and then I asked all the girls would you
prefer men that's more sexual experience
than you or less sexual experience than
you all of them said I would prefer man
that was more sexual experience than me
because they don't want to see you have
to like stumble like if a girl shy
doesn't know what she's doing that's
more attractive like you could teach her
a girl doesn't want to teach you yeah
because then I also will make her feel
like a too and she's teaching you
yeah yeah like if you really think about
it like when a girl's in a driver's seat
teaching you how to bang like that makes
her feel like a because she's like
damn I'm more sexual experience than
this guy like damn so a girl always just
like a woman wants a guy stronger than
her she also wants a guy's more sexual
experience than her too okay let me
let me let me be a bit controversial
they may be a bit controversial not
intentionally but it might it might be
it might sound like that
what they're saying is Battle it's
falsehood go sleep around Etc
now and I say this to non-muslim men
the things that you want to do
like you know the Haram looks very
appealing look it is true
that for example
if a man
has argument's sake and we can carry
this on to Islam yeah let's talk about
Islam they're talking about it from a
Haram point of view a man sleeping
around and having sexual experience Etc
let's suppose that yes a woman I mean
there might be some studies that show
this that's a woman likes a man that
knows what he's doing no problem let's
go with it no problem now that can be
done in a Halal way how if a man has a
wife he's married yeah now of course
when he is married his sexual urges are
a bit controlled because he has a wife
that he can be intimate with now this
what this does is it boosts a man's
confidence and we know due to the
hypergamous nature of women a woman
likes a man inside this is the nature
woman it's like that they find interest
in in a man who has a wife or a
girlfriend I've seen this in jahilia I'm
being honest with you we've seen it with
Brothers like in jahilia where a brother
uh argument said you don't have a
girlfriend nobody wants to know you the
moment you get a girlfriend all of a
sudden the attention from other girls
are increased why so we understand the
psychology of women so what I'm saying
is as a as a man you can be married and
then when you're married alhamdulillah
you are obviously less desperate you
start moving less desperate so it can be
that your second wife will be more
intrigued with you if she's more
interested in you there'll be women that
want to marry you Halas do this so we're
not seeing no to it we're just seeing
then let's say there is some facts to
what they say but that doesn't mean you
have to be promiscuous what we're seeing
is Islam is giving you a solution if you
are a high value man and not from their
content from a red pill I'm talking
about high value man who might have
money wealth Etc but forget that a man
of talk a man who fears Allah a man who
gives the rights of Allah a man who
protects him from major sins doesn't go
steep around a man who has a wife and if
you have those capabilities go get
married again
yeah because then you will have some
experience as a man being intimate with
your first wife no problem let's go with
the argument fine just do it the Halal
way and there is nothing wrong with this
some Muslims might listen to this and be
like oh my gosh like what are you
talking about this is from Islam getting
married again second or third so what
all it means is yes you are a man who
because he's got married two wives
whatever maybe you are experienced with
women and therefore you might appeal to
more woman let's go with it but the
point is what again Islam gives you a
solution a Halal solution not a Haram
Solution by going and sleeping around
and committing zinnar this has
consequences and only that you are
initially and this is what I find a bit
ironic um a bit hypocritical to the red
pill you don't want you you dislike
women who sleep around but then you go
and see go sleep around
I don't understand women should should
be virgins okay but we're the ones
that's going to go and take all the
vegetarian virginities away hey brother
you're the one who's causing the problem
in the system yeah so it doesn't make
sense stay away from it Islam has given
you a proper solution have another wife
second wife third wife a wife wife not a
girlfriend not a side chick not a
mistress so I thought maybe from that
angle maybe it would change their mind
to like okay this can be practiced not
sleeping around but if you want to be
experienced with women in a righteous
way you honor these women you marry this
woman you look after this woman you have
that experience because you have two
wives do that so what's the Halal way to
learn how to do that stuff there you go
I just told you one thing there you go
there you go I I just told you there you
go there's a Halal way because supposed
to have sex outside of marriage how do
you learn how to like pull a hair and
choke properly or like the right amount
of velocity to slap with without that
experience like how you would have to
get islamically married like and just
get a chick and then experiment with her
and then just if you got the money and
the resource and the ability to do so
marry another chick and do the same with
her if you're gonna do it you know
within the confinements uh of keeping a
Halal is that how you would it's a
simple process look like getting married
he knows no that's the solution in my
room you said it was your own mouth you
you know this bro how could you know
this and no implement it bro Islam is
giving you the solution and before some
people watch this and be like oh my gosh
is woman just something no we're talking
about a wife he marries her he's with
her he has kids with her he's spending
his life with her and also gets married
again is the same we're not talking
about marrying just for the sake of this
and get some experience and then Chuck
no no no no no no that's why Islam has
got protocols in place to protect the
woman speak to the
wallyma all these things are there why
because genuinely as a man if you allow
a man to sleep with a hundred woman he's
gonna do it that's the reason why
Allah's put these protocols in place so
a man is in check that if he wants to do
it he's like here is old obstacles that
I have to go through and then Marry Her
Like tough yeah you can have a someone
was saying like you could have a nickel
and then it just like you just need one
witness pretty much and then you you
could even divorce all you have to do is
say divorce three times yeah yeah it's
very yeah it's really it's very simple
so like to the outside world right
people that aren't Muslims or whatever
like they will look at it as like uh
it's a boyfriend or girlfriend but
technically you guys are islamically
married so everything you do is hello
and then you could I'm not saying I'm
not advocating for this but in theory
you could yeah
it's kind of like it's a theory you
could like marry one chick islamically
have sex with her everything is halal
then if she pisses you off get rid of
her or keep her and then marry another
girl divorce divorce how do you say
divorce divorce yeah how do you say
divorce I don't know how to say it
in Arabic thank you for the 20 Alibaba
not Myron that was death that's the way
to put it
um marriage is mizowage if I'm not
mistaken so much
um his marriage Alibaba is not mine
though it's a death the best way to put
it but we never know when we gonna die
so repent back soon repentance should
put you back on the straight path and
you should be good I'm also on this
journey
another sign coming his way yeah yeah
exactly and also um yeah the only thing
I disagree with is this um marine and
then if you don't like her and just
divorce her you know a woman is not a um
she's not she's not an object you just
you know just marry and just you know
I'm not seeing that that can't be done
but you know the scholars say the name
because valid if you if you're marrying
with the intention of divorce you you
are committed it is a sin but then a cow
is valid but again you need to be very
careful of your treatment of others
because at the end of the day the salaf
used to say we would rather stand in
front of Allah with 70 sins between us
and our Lord then one sin that we wrong
somebody Islam gives great emphasis on
the right of a human being great great
great emphasis so we talked about the
three conditions if you want to repent
right there's a fourth condition added
if you wrong somebody so if you go and
wrong somebody arguments Take You Back
by somebody this the school is broken
down to such a level that you need to
ask for their forgiveness
for the repentance to be accepted yeah
now if you the scholar say if you go to
them and say by the way I spoke bad of
you and this action what you said might
cause resentment they say it's better
you don't tell them but rather wherever
you went and spoke ill of them speak
good of them and given charity in their
name and make Dua for them this is the
right Allah has given to the wronging
wronging the right of another human
being so we need to be very careful this
attitude of women are like disposable
Goods these are our sisters these are
our mothers these are our daughters this
attitude is not correct you wouldn't
want that to happen to your daughter
would you want me coming and saying yeah
you do I'm gonna marry I don't like I'm
gonna say talaq no and just to touch
upon maybe non-muslims watching this the
talaq actually
says the reason why the talaq was given
is to keep the man in check you're
thinking how how does a talaki the
manager because it seems like he's the
one who has the power number one we know
from studies that women initiate divorce
more than men if women had the power of
talaq me and brother Eddie will be
andisha will be getting divorced by our
wives every three three and a half
minutes
okay so the thing is here it's there to
keep keep them in check
um in that aspect where we have the
power now
the Pagan Arabs used to abuse the power
of tala so what they would do is they
would say I divorce you the woman would
want to move on with their life they
were saying I'll take you back
then they would you know take them back
when they bought whatever I divorce you
she wants to move on with her life no I
take you back and there was an endless
cycle there was no limits Allah limited
it to three to keep the man in check
that you can't abuse this power you give
talaq once good she has to eat that
period you take her back no problem
same thing you take a back no problem
third time you're in trouble because
third time it means that this woman is
going to go and get married has to go
and get married to another man have
intimacy with him have him be married
and if it doesn't work out then you can
marry and try again but for a man to
Envision his wife with another man this
is why the talaq is there to keep the
man in check so he's like if I give the
third talab that means that the Forum
the man is contemplating
she's going to be with another man if he
gives that talaki means he doesn't care
about that it's gone beyond that now so
the talaq is there not for the just for
the power of man but it's to keep him in
check so if a woman wants to move on she
can move I'm willing to give up the um
the three or fours for Halal wives what
is this uh some new slang what is this
yeah basically promiscuous woman
that's what a 304 is yeah they call them
304s
okay so you know about this in London
also huh not really I think if I think
it's an American thing but but yeah I
got the just like they'll keep repeating
I was like what does that mean but yeah
yeah you do you we had a debate about
this on the last panel I want to ask
like four wives is really not enough to
to put the um the toilet girls aside
well
I like the variety man I'm not gonna lie
I'm not gonna sit here and try to Virtue
signal and lie down be like oh no I'm
going to try like I I genuinely do like
the variety
so I mean I I've tried I like smoking
weed
I don't smoke weed anymore
yeah but weed is actually like bad for
your health and but are bad
for your health it can be before they're
bad for your pockets yeah well if you
wear a condoms and don't be an idiot
you'll be straight come on
come on
like bro no one likes condoms man hey I
do use them I do use them I actually do
use them but there's other ones every
single time but I do use them a good
amount but it's not even just bad for
it's bad for your pockets it's also bad
for your time true true but it doesn't
have to say I would I would argue that
weed and drugs is a worse Vice than
females all right so for here they
pretty much uh they're going back and
forth debating uh what's worse now uh
alcohol and weed which uh we commend
Nico who just recently accepted Islam
and just like Tate also he gave up
alcohol smoking weed and now he's trying
to get himself right to find himself uh
to have any car and he's trying to
persuade his brother here Marlin to uh
come along here and to get serious about
the dean
what are your comments uh what do you
what do you think uh with the way
they're going back and forth and with
the debate what which Vice is worse I
think the thing is yeah I think they're
both in us they obviously they're both
searching uh you know that's what they
say these things which they they don't
really versed on it's just they're like
you know what do we do they're just
trying to rationalize it what's worse
Etc to us Allah has made it very clear
what Allah says is that I don't need to
think of like oh this is where if we
look at this and that let's calculate
this this is more harmful Allah has made
the Haram it's as simple as that is
this one this one has an effect of out
of 10 9.3 and this one is 9.7 Allah
a lot easier for you exactly simple so
so I would say um to Myron to keep uh
sneak or close by he's a good friend
he's somebody that's calling you to good
um and yeah look I I would I'll be
honest with you
um this couple of months ago before
sneaker even came to Islam many maybe
even a year ago people have been telling
me to you know get in contact with Niko
Etc I I've just really really been
occupied with a few projects I have no
problem sitting down with them because
he's genuinely looking
um I I would love to sit and talk with
him and break things down nicely you
know step by step because I think
there's he's got good problems around
him as well but if you want to I'll be
more than happy to to speak to him and
Myron if he wants to again look I'm not
doing this for clicks well like I can
talk to you guys off camera all day
every day we don't need to be on camera
at all you can contact me like on my
number whatever bro we can sit down we
can have this meeting without it being
on YouTube just like this as long as
it's going to benefit you guys bro I'm
at your service like please like you
don't need me I'm a noble there's many
better people if you want to I'm here so
at least there's no like you know I'm
reaching out if you want to off camera
however you like on cam I don't mind
it's on camera it's not a must whatever
you guys want I just want to inshallah
give a little advice as your brother and
yeah that's it and benefit from you guys
as well I'm sure there's a lot of things
I can learn from you guys and yeah let's
just sit down and let's talk and and
yeah it's it's that's all I can say and
I relate with you guys I live that kind
of Lifestyle
um and yeah we'll we'll have a lot of
things in common yeah this is so
important is having good friends as the
saying goes you're you're you're upon uh
you know as a professor of sunset the
person is on the the way the religion of
his friends so be careful who you
befriend so if you're with friends who
are always trying to take you to the
nightclub smoking weed dope uh hooking
up alcohol
and you're trying to be right like Cinco
is trying to be right but he's still got
all these other friends who are doing
the same jahlia stuff they're going to
venture you're going to get tempted and
it's you know you're gonna have your
highs and lows and then you're on your
low boom you're gonna end up back in the
club and then you can end up falling
again
uh so go ahead let's
here's another thing we'll go ahead and
react to this it's the last one I think
this is very powerful here because
there's another
some have called him the uh manager to
Andrew Tate I had him in the studio here
very very nice brother he's uh he's a
good friend with the Tates his uh
brother Jewel
and now pay attention how another sign
is coming to the both of them and I
believe this uh other part of Myron the
other the other person here he's looks
like he comes from the Muslim background
himself so let's go ahead and get into
this alhamdulillah you should bring
Myron to the Masjid don't worry I will
make my return to the motion I'd love to
speak on that so I was I was in the
mustard before coming here
half of them are Muslim and like I
understand you know on some of what the
Quran stands for Quran stands for what
the religion stands for and I do respect
it 100 I just right now I'm not decided
yet I feel that man I feel that but look
I put it to you at some point in your
life I think any rational male who wants
to live with traditional gender norms
and wants to be you know what it's okay
to have those sorts of beliefs it's okay
to be that old school guy who believes
in honor who believes in the importance
of the family unit who rejects Hedonism
I would like to think that every logical
man reading the chessboard will actually
think you know what Islam makes a lot of
sense because for me I get a lot of
positive emotions from it it was purely
a logical choice so I'd say to everyone
out there who's thinking wait a second
my my values don't match this Western
degeneracy my values don't match all
this liberal soy programming I would I
would recommend everyone have a look at
Islam because there's a lot older than
we are then there's a lot of guidance in
there which is extremely relevant for
the plight of masculinity today
absolutely I mean it solves a lot of the
western problems so I'll solve them
actually like uh again I'd say to every
man who's engaging in a lot of you know
spinning plates or a lot of a lot of
short term relationships every one of
those is a potential time bomb that 10
years later can cause you a lot of
problems you've got to look and see risk
versus return is that as I said that 2
p.m you know miserable intimacy really
worth planting landmines that can then
bite you 10 years later should a certain
woman decide oh hang on a sec I I didn't
enjoy something about that experience
even though I was completely consensual
and there was nothing illegal I'm going
to say I felt that it was illegal that
can end your career that could end your
your reputation like it's really serious
I think a lot of young men aren't aware
of how serious it is what do you think
that this is really deep now for
profound to have like on this show Allah
sends Jewel that's the brother Jewel and
he's breaking it down he's giving these
brothers nasiha right there you could
you you couldn't have planned it's
better on this uh on this uh Russian fit
whatever you call it show and the
brother is actually agreeing again Myron
he's not fighting back he's he's uh
acknowledging this now it's the
difference between acknowledging and
action and then the other guy didn't
know he's it seems like he's he's Muslim
his family's Muslim or the yeah he's
he's I think I saw him he's a bit he's
like he said I don't know I saw some
videos he's like I think he's a
Christian half Muslim or something like
that but he ended up in Juma and then
another sign is coming to him and the
Imam is talking about what we're talking
about same thing is it worth that moment
of pleasure the Haram that now you're
going to sacrifice your Hereafter that's
eternity what do you have to say forget
I was like 15 14 years old I went to
Baltimore to visit family they're Muslim
of course and I was in a Masjid and
they're speaking in depression uh at
that point and one of the the I guess
the head
um what do you call the head guy
speaking the shake it did he was saying
my mom was like listen are you gonna
trade your
um your religion your beliefs everything
for one
bit of moment of sweetness of sex like
your whole life for a little bit of sex
and I was like damn he said five minutes
of pleasure and I was like damn that
stood up to me however I will say I'm
fighting that battle right now myself
deep in the trenches brother trying to
figure it out but yeah I get where you
say 100 percent
yeah I mean if you if you look at it
Allah seems like Allah is sending signs
and Allah does this you know why so on
the day of judgment
when your life is taken you cannot say I
did not know
from snico to the sky Left Right Center
this message Islam is all over so Allah
is sending clear signs to these people
and many people are watching it that to
turn back to Allah before it's too late
and I don't know what else to say like
you know they are there they're talking
about that the guy himself is saying you
know we want Myron to return back to the
Masjid Etc that's an outright sign from
Allah Allah wants goodness for you but
if you persist and think like yeah I've
got time who promised you you promised
you this time my lights to me to know
very simple to know that I can die any
moment is an evidence that I am more
closer to the Hereafter than I am to
this life
to know that I can die any moment is a
clear-cut evidence that I am more closer
to death than I am to life
mm-hmm as simple as that this is deep
it's almost finished let's go ahead oh
look man I'm 40 years old and I I'm a
man of means I I've engaged in
sufficient Hedonism to realize that it's
it's genuinely a waste of time however
when you choose what's known as
within Islam when you choose that
straight path when you're living in a
very ethical very clean life where
you're avoiding all that nonsense which
we know is a waste of time anyway yeah
the the energy that you have the
discipline you have on a day-to-day
basis it's it's a competitive Advantage
I am infinitely more disciplined capable
effective and and driven than I was
before becoming Muslim simply by
rejecting all that nonsense and choosing
a system for life which is very very
ethical very clean very energetically
um high level you go into clubs where
people are drinking taking drugs it
drags you down energies yeah if you take
Islam seriously every day you're getting
a positive uplifting energy as opposed
to the degeneracy which pulls you down
it's real man I wouldn't have chosen it
if it wasn't and I'm taking it really
seriously because I see even on a
selfish level I see the benefits in
myself but again that makes me a better
you know father makes me a better
contributor to society it really is it's
a superpower to make yourself a more
effective human that's my personal
experience what do you think is the
biggest thing that like was like the
biggest change converting to Islam like
improved was it like maybe cutting out
the alcohol was it cutting out any type
of
what was it that made like propelled you
okay so a lot of people say they found
Islam at their hardest times I found
Islam in my best times you know
alhamdulillah everything is like my life
is custom-made reality I practice what I
preach there's nothing I change in my
life everything is you know
alhamdulillah is incredible however at a
certain point of success whether it's
material or status all these things you
do wonder what's next Islam will give
you a whole level of depth that you
don't really know you're missing until
you've stepped into and gone oh hang on
a second there's a real Brotherhood in
the Uma there's a real sense of
community there I've had incredible
support coming in but I'd say the number
one thing is I have real accountability
now and this is actually why I chose
Islam in the first place Muslims who
take their faith seriously Every Act
every every action every interaction
they realize they're accountable to a
higher Force they realize they'll be
judged you know at the end of their life
so they are almost forcing themselves
the ones who take the faith seriously to
act in a way that we know we should
anyway
so for me as a man who knew I shouldn't
drink knew I shouldn't engage in certain
things I can now cut that out and I've
got a very strong sort of
even more powerful than
self-accountability I have
accountability to what I view to be the
most powerful you know entity or being
in the world that is a very strong way
to keep yourself on that straight path
you know I mean especially you've got
your money right you got status right
there's a lot of Temptation there let's
be real it is not hard to live a life of
Hedonism nowadays yeah whereas Islam to
me is that that push to make sure that
you are ignoring that and you're
focusing on what you know is Meaningful
what you know is beneficial for your
family for your Brotherhood for society
it just it keeps you disciplined that's
the number one benefit I've experienced
right so uh in closing now
there was a lot set there he talks about
uh it's a waste of time a jewel going on
to explain you know all the benefits and
this is somebody who again the Dunya has
opened up to him he's went down that
life of debauchery you know changing
women and just to hear him on the
program actually giving the siha advice
to these to both of these uh Brothers
here you know this just amazes me also
you couldn't have planned this Allah is
the best of planners look at it now it's
on them like you were saying also this
is that those signs that come
and to reflect you know to really think
about it and it's interesting when the
when these things when people are really
in a state of consciousness they're
listening like they're listening to him
they're absorbing but then now what are
you going to do with it and then you go
on in life and you forget and you go
back into the Hedonism you go into you
know uh you know fulfilling your lusts
and desires you're not around good
company someone to remind you that's why
it's so so important to be around
Brothers like that be around Brothers
you know who are going to remind you who
are going to strengthen you help you now
brothers are going to be like hey you
ready to go hook up you're ready to go
get some 304s how does that go yeah
literally
yeah yes finally yeah it is you know at
the end of the day Allah guides and to
me like I said before uh to see that
these people like themselves who are
living that kind of lifestyle and this
time came for them you know I'll do that
when Speakers Corner every Sunday and
you know I was there I was trying to
like there was some party happening and
there was a lot of like there's a lot of
gay people there were trans people and I
was trying to stop them and one brother
was like oh you know why are you
stopping them
I said brother Islam came for them do
you think some came for the righteous
Islam came for these people Islam came
for the ones that are lost so the thing
is there it's that seeing these people
who are coming from that lifestyle Islam
came for them to make them a better
person to make them the best version of
their self and only Islam can give them
that you can never become a high value
man whatever your name you just put
money and this that when you're
spiritually dead you know you're
spiritually starving so these people
have been literally like that and now
when they come to istan they understand
they realize because when you are
dealing with materialistic things you
think this is the only form of pleasure
when you understand and once Allah gives
you the sweetness of Faith you realize
what real pleasure is about you then
realize and say you know what oh my gosh
all this time I was thinking what having
girls money get out of here please to
know that you're spiritually satisfied
and to know that you're while you're
here where you're going having a purpose
being content I'm telling you it is the
best form of uh you know pleasure can
have that's what Allah says in the Quran
only in my remembrance do hearts find
peace and if you forget my remembrance
you will have a depressed life in this
life the only thing that gives us
contentment is the remembrance of our
Lord and in Jannah what is the best
thing that we're gonna have in gender
hold a lane no
it's the face of Allah
we are going to see Allah
that is the Pinnacle of pleasure in
Jannah forget all this Quran and this
time to see Allah and be all
that's what it is so in this life and
the Hereafter it is only Allah gives us
content and happiness at the end of the
day now when someone looks at these are
the things that see there they have some
doubts so Byron Ernie and if they have
some doubles they should connect with
people of knowledge to clear these
doubts and then there's desires those
are the things that usually hinder
people from really submitting themselves
fully and following some properly so
what advice what other advice do you
have now obviously you know some anybody
who really looks into Islam like Jewel
did you know and others Nico when you
look at the evidence and proof without a
shadow of a doubt without a shadow of a
doubt that it is indeed not man-made or
from a group of men it is Deed from the
creator of the heavens and earth the
authenticity of the Quran the
preservation all the signs that are in
their prophecies you know the prophet
saws life if you look at his life you
know too much to talk about now but you
can go ahead and look into this and now
when when you realize you know death is
a reality we talked about that we talked
about the Hellfire Paradise when you put
things in perspective that you can die
at any time you know really think about
that that should be should be a
motivation now to take that take those
steps now towards what we've been
talking about this whole time do you
think exactly exactly that's what it is
you know at the end of the day you know
that's what I'll say um you know
open in the Quran and also having that
connection with Allah making Dua asking
you know my Lord guide me that's all it
takes man people confuse this matter and
make it so difficult but just turn to
your lord is that it's really hard you
know is it so damn hard to to put your
hands up and say my Lord please guide me
that's it I'm sincere sincerely looking
for guidance and you can see that
without maybe even asking Allah is
sending people like sneako and this
other brother to you imagine what could
happen if you ask him
it's as simple as that the recipe is
simple the recipe is simple it's the
Quran it's simple
I'm going to give Myron some homework
real simple basic uh before he goes to
his next after party or he goes uh why
don't he start or before we get to this
party part start going to jummah start
praying at least what we know it's
obligatory five times a day start
playing one time a day how's that one
time and it start with one time Byron
you could do that
if he doesn't know how to pray our
charity Salam we have a guided prayer
mat beautiful I'll send it for free
whatever you want it doesn't need to be
addressed it's a guided prayer mat that
shows you step by step how to pray you
can pray immediately you just put in
front of you and you follow it we can
teach you look off camera I don't want
to be on camera I don't want credit I
don't want nothing it doesn't even have
to be me if you don't want it to be me
it can be someone else we just want
goodness for you I will send that prayer
mat to sneak out to my run to anyone who
wants it because people have donated to
it people donated it we will love for
you guys to pray we'll send it
so you got that free what excuses you
got now start praying once a week Juma
make the time go sneakers going go to
Juma with him
start praying one time and say and then
start building from there simple right
and uh get these girlfriends the 304s
into uh or the whatever they call the
other ones until just leave them and
just find yeah proper woman
yeah we'll go from there hopefully
insurance it's gonna be a benefit we did
this yeah
so seriously this is out of the love for
these brothers we want good from her we
come from that you come from that back
that history that lifestyle we've been
there we've done that and alhamdulillah
I'm telling you what this is the way uh
just like jewel is saying uh the same
thing we're repeating the same thing
hopefully now it's on them they can feel
the love look at really the place
sincerity we're coming from and they can
start to you know Implement some of
these things and see this is another
sign that's coming to them inshallah
thank you Ali no problem it was a
pleasure and inshallah look forward to
seeing you in Chicago in November
inshallah also at the the dean Center
yeah
[Music]
yeah all right guys so we signed
everything here
[Music]
[Applause]
Muslims around here it's it's pretty
huge and uh like this the place the
location that you opened in basically
it's far further south from the other
other big massages and everyone I know a
lot of people that I used to I come my
cousin lives nine minutes from here
another Uncle of mine lives about five
to ten minutes from
in an area that it's much needed and
this size yeah I mean this the center
this Center is much needed for this area
and the idea of this Center is needed
for the whole stick because we don't
have anything like that in the whole
state that that wasn't there where it's
gonna basically nurture and basically
educate and it's gonna basically spread
Islam
I'm really looking forward to because we
need to be meaning to raise funds for
that as well so we can do some videos
and I can use it finally inshallah it's
been very very hectic for me uh but yeah
definitely inshallah may Allah bless it
and have you guys reached the amount yet
or you you guys no we put we purchased
the property now we're in phase two
build out remodeling oh perfect okay
yeah I would look I would love to if
there's any when I come I don't mind you
know painting if there's anything you
need me to do I want to be Hands-On I
don't want it to be just like a video so
I'm more than happy to come help if
there's anything to do well I would
genuinely I like I'm a Hands-On guy you
know as you know when I deal with Tommy
Robinson and you know these kind of
people I deal with them face to face so
when it comes to the machine inshallah I
don't want to just help raise funds I
also want to be involved in Charlotte if
his painting I'm good at some stuff yeah
don't get twisted I can I can I can do
some stuff so it'll be nice
thank you brother
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you